is this a picture of Muhammad something
won't be up at 5:30 this morning maybe
it was my conscience maybe it was God
take your pick
I'll go for conscience in any case this
week Canada's government is going to
consider an anti Islamophobia motion mo
103 in Parliament before that happens I
have some things to say Moses was a
murderer Christ was a bastard and
Mohammed Mohammed was a Muhammad was a
Muhammad was a holy man whose every word
and action was correct
I asked Muslims worldwide can I say
anything else on the week Canada's
government is going to discuss anti
Islamophobia emotion m103 in Parliament
I asked Muslims worldwide can I say
anything else asked Muslims in the West
can I say anything else I asked Muslims
in Canada can I say anything else I
asked it cracka lead sponsor of m103 in
Canada can I say anything else is this a
picture of Mohammed where do I cross the
line this is a picture of Christ this is
a picture of mole this is a picture of
mole this is a picture of Moses this is
a picture of mole this is a picture of
is this a picture of Muhammad this might
be a picture of Muhammad did I cross the
line when do I become salman rushdie I'm
a westerner I am a Solomon rusty dhikr
Khalid are you sellin rusty when do I
become a Danish cartoonist I'm a
westerner I am a Danish cartoonist it
Khalid are you a Danish cartoonist when
do I become Charlie Hebdo I'm a
westerner I can criticize so that things
can improve so that we're not trapped in
the dead past so that we're not trapped
in the embrace of the corpses of the
past I am Charlie Hebdo ikura Khalid
are you Charlie Hebdo which side are you
on
every Westerner is Salman Rushdie every
Westerner is a Danish cartoonist every
Westerner is Charlie Hebdo who is a
crackling when push comes to shove as it
will this week where is she going to
stand Muslims of the world on the week
of anti Islamophobia motion 103 in
Canada Muslims of the West on the week
of anti Islamophobia motion 103 in
Canada Muslims of Canada on the week of
anti Islamophobia emotion 103 in Canada
Iker Khalid of Canada who sponsored the
motion after the murders in Quebec City
on the week of anti Islamophobia motion
103 in Canada can I say this is a
picture of the Prophet Mohammed
because if I can't it's not Islamophobia
is this a picture of Muhammad
is this a picture of Muhammad